did you guys hear did you hear about the
fact that Zuckerberg's net worth
declined he lost a hundred billion
dollars in his Network I asked you about
that like is that true and you're like
oh this happened yeah I didn't believe
it he lost a hunt put up the story from
Fortune he lost a hundred billion
dollars uh here's a story from Vice
Facebook's Monopoly is imploding before
our eyes for years the definition of
success for many Tech employees has been
getting a job at Fang companies like
Facebook Amazon Apple Netflix Google but
there's evidence that Facebook is under
uh uh uh uh here give me this word here
precipice uh precipitous precipice
precipice of dropping out of the group
uh out of this group through years of
sheer mismanagement of failure to
innovate setting money on fire in
pursuit of metaverse that seemingly no
one wants a vulnerable business model
that apple is squarely taking aim at and
upstart competitors like Tick Tock that
the com uh company seemingly has no
answer to in a little over one year the
company has shared nearly you ready
folks 800 billion dollars of its market
cap nearly a trillion dollars wow with
the Lions share of that coming these
past eight months reality Labs
Facebook's metaverse fantasy team burned
through four and a half billion dollars
in 2019 6.6 billion in 2020 and 10.1
billion dollars in 2021 that's a total
of 21 billion dollars another 9.4
billion dollars in losses has been
realized in 2020 to bring in reality
Labs operating losses to north of 31
billion dollars and that's Facebook Tom
when you see the story
with Facebook and Zuck what do you think
about is this somebody said the other
day on Twitter I don't know who it was
they said look now that muskbot Twitter
can somebody buy Facebook Okay can
somebody go out there and buy Facebook
how bad is it at Facebook right now I'd
like to apologize to everybody for my
deep energy analysis and I will thank
you for comments that I should keep it
more simple and I'll take it right back
to simple in this Facebook is not
getting consumers from the new
generation so old Facebook think of it
as a gas powered engine Zuckerberg
thinks that metaverse is his EV that the
old product is not going to be there
long term and it's not growing in ad
value and it's not growing in customers
especially the generation Zia knew so he
has to bet on something else and he's
sitting there like Thomas Edison saying
call me crazy if you will but I gotta
invent something else that's going to
bring me Revenue tomorrow and it is the
metaverse so I think it's that simple
what he's looking at by the way did you
did you hear what Jim Cramer did on Mad
Money a couple days ago he almost cried
on the already apologized oh he actually
did cry he cried saying I apologize he
was talking to David Faber for telling
people that Facebook is a good
investment and Facebook stocks not done
very well so it's been it's been a
little bit challenging but he was crying
yeah you can see the interview go it
just goes the show nobody knows what
direction the market or a stock is going
Jim Cramer who's the quote unquote
expert about everything comes to stock
market Finance is now crying on air
because of his wrong speculation that's
why it's so hard to do that week for
CNBC because uh Deirdre Bossa is that
her name dear to Bossa um she also
apologized because she got completely
Hoodwinked on the uh the the fake
Twitter engineer story so it was a tough
week
well a couple things about Facebook
because I obviously I'll ask young
people questions I'm like are you on
Facebook they're like no I don't like
once you saw your grandma or your mom on
Facebook yeah I'm out I'm off this
platform what am I talking about here
and
and rightfully so the direction like are
your daughters on Facebook uh no no
because you're on it Tom nobody's trying
to hang out with you bro
it was a joke so just put your your
daughters are not off you can stop
yelling but you're absolutely correct
that's what I'm saying like but the
point is that like your daughters aren't
trying to affiliate with their father or
grandfather on Facebook because it's not
a thing but the pivot that Facebook is
not cool or interesting exactly face but
you are so don't take that as a knock
the the
um
the the pivot to meta
when was at the height of the crypto
Market the height of Bitcoin the height
of Dogecoin the hype of ethereum and
then we've seen what's happened with the
crash of crypto nfts have lost what 90
of their value over the last six 12
months so like talk about timing like
guys great idea we're gonna change
Facebook to meta crypto's the hottest
thing in the world we're doing the
metaverse thing
like we've seen what's happened Italian
I don't know if you could pull this up I
would love to know in 2020
the height of Zuckerberg's wealth like
where was he on the top 20 list maybe
number four or five and where he is
today I would love to add him on that
also you can lay over the political
environment because remember a lot of
Democrats blamed Zuckerberg for not
being tough enough and allowing the
Trump election to take place with all
the shenanigans so he ends up in front
of Congress on safety issues on protocol
issues on foreign intervention so the
old Facebook was Under Fire and the old
Facebook isn't getting new cons
consumers as you just pointed out from
my daughter's generation so guess what
the entrepreneur that Zuckerberg says
I'm inventing my way out and I think
it's that simple and the pain they're
going through the reason that Facebook
is dropping isn't because he's investing
in metaverse the reason Facebook is
dropping is because ad revenue is
dropping subscribership is dropping for
sure all those consumers aren't there so
while the thing is going down Zuckerberg
is not getting credit will it work I
don't know if metaverse is going to work
I don't think it will but he's not
getting credit for being the
entrepreneur trying to invent himself
out of the hole well Pat let me tee this
up for you you posted something I don't
know a couple weeks ago you're saying
like if you look at the Fortune 500
companies from 1950 like how many are
still in it today great point and it was
like 50 of companies I don't remember
but like just because a company is the
top dog does not guarantee that they
will be the top dog 10 20 50 years from
now what were those do you remember
those six set like 70 60 of Fortune 500
companies from 1970 are no longer even
in business so just insane yeah which is
insane so look but we're on this right
but but I will tell you I don't think
it's because zuck's not being Innovative
I don't think it's because he's you know
but he went all in on nfts and meta and
it backfired right as great of a product
they may be producing with 31 billion
dollars into it
the market said no we're not going to it
may happen in the next 10 years it may
happen in the next five years it's just
not happening right now due to where the
where the markets and Tyler just pulled
this up in 2020 he was the fifth richest
person in the world uh this may be 2021.
okay even 2021 exactly so conservatives
also don't trust Facebook generally
speaking nobody because of the collusion
that happened between uh Zuckerberg and
fauci and the whole team on that stuff
they don't trust that but I always say
Facebook reminds me of cable news it's
like I hate to say it this way but the
audience is is dying I mean they're very
old these are very old people so they
have to like re-energize they ha you
have to get those Tick Tock people to
want to come over to Facebook for some
reason and why I feel like Twitter has
its own brand it's where you go to kind
of have that debate the discussion I
totally get the appeal of Twitter I also
get the appeal of tick tock because it's
like these little sound bites I get the
Young Generation that has no attention
spam blah what is Facebook doing really
that's unique and why last word let me
just say this though let me just say
this still in two years do not be
surprised whoever gets elected in 2024
2025 if they choose to ban Tick Tock
then in 2025 the app that could take off
is Instagram and Instagram will get all
the people from Tick Tock that'll move
over and by the way most of our Clips do
better on Instagram right now than
they're doing on Tick Tock if those
people move over Facebook will be back
up again but in the next two years uh
it'll have a lot to do with somebody
taking down Tick Tock in the states give
it a last word and a tip of the hat to
certain types of leadership
um who is responsible for the 10-year
run at Facebook who is responsible for
the economic plan
for the 10-year Cheryl Sandberg that is
correct it was recently departed that's
right so I said a certain type of
leadership there was to one of the most
influential best I don't agree with her
book everything on lean in but there's
parts of it that I love in terms of my
daughters but she came out there female
in leadership at the top of tech and
drove this thing and a lot of the
mistakes and things that happened she
and Zuckerberg had a falling out so
let's face it she was retired let's
understand what happened here
um in the face of the stuff that was
going on but he also lost his number two
that drove the company to where it was
yeah and Pat has a very good point about
let's not underplay the fact that he
changed his entire company name very
risky entire brand to the metaverse yeah
he changed his entire company to meta
not like hey this is a branch of what we
do no he's the entire company is meta
now so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]